another dice trick
three dice they're normal d6s i'm gonna
turn away and ask you to handle the dice
is that okay yeah so i'm gonna face the
lovely ladder here can you st you can
roll them if you want to make sure it's
random but can you then stack the dice
one on top of the other
okay
i want to watch this because i suspect
you're doing this with just one hand and
that's quite maybe impressive are they
stacked not yet hang on all right
underestimated how difficult this was
it's not easy when you're holding a
camera but i'm sure you're up to the
task
i have stacked them okay can you please
just carefully pick up the top dice and
look at the two faces that are touching
and add them together okay the two faces
touching is that add them together yeah
and that i've added them together okay
can you do the same with the next pair
of faces that are touching so pick up
the top two dice and and add the two
faces that are touching okay so we've
got that and that okay and then you can
pick up the whole stack and check the
bottom number and add that onto your
total as well
okay yep okay um are you done yep you've
got that running total in your head oh
sorry can you cover up the pile now uh i
think we got a hat ready to do this
available now
so can i turn around now yep
so you have a number on your head yep
and not only were the faces hidden uh on
the stack they were also covered by a
hat now there's no way i can know the
number you're thinking of
but it is 19.
oh it is 19 yeah
[Laughter]
dice tricks are silly
because everyone knows there's a trick
like dice are not tricky objects these
are not loaded die and it wouldn't help
me if they were
so like always the way with magic tricks
if you want to work them out try and
repeat them but this time i'll i'll deal
with the the theater of me looking away
i'm just going to stay looking so i'd be
looking away i wouldn't see any of this
stuff and i'm still looking away and you
check the two touching faces here
there's a five and a five so you've got
ten good and then there's a
six so 16 all together and you get the
last one
get that right sorry
i'd do better with the camera yeah it's
uh i should just started to carry on
down the bottom one is three yeah
what are we on
19 19 again
so is it always 19
yeah
let's try one more i'll do it all right
let's see if i can get better with this
so rolling them randomly yeah stacking
them
uh
there's a four and a one five five
plus eleven nice eleven sixteen and the
bottom one
two
makes
17 yeah so it's not always 90. but we've
done that wrong it is not always 19
we can't add up for some reason let's
check this i'm curious now
four and one is five yeah
plus eleven six sixteen
plus two eighteen that's seventeen
eighty sixteen plus two is eighty
eighteen
what's going on we we're both uh
what's going on worse of mental
arithmetic than well i think i'm pretty
bad anyway there's one bit of this trick
which is more magic trixie than some of
the others that i've been doing i have
to do one clever thing and then lots of
stuff which is just not clever at all
you we've been doing some other dice
tricks today uh there's a famous fact
about d6s which i know you know tell me
about that the opposite sides add to
seven do you think that helps here
yes i do but we're looking at touching
faces not opposite faces right but four
of our faces are opposite to each other
so we're guaranteed to get to 14.
right
because two of the sevens are going to
come out yeah yeah so the one that
doesn't get paired
is that one in the top one yeah so we're
in 14 plus that
is there any way i could know
well if you saw the top number yeah
you'll know what's did i see the top
number
well you shouldn't have
do you remember what happened when i
asked you to put the hat on
no i turned around and said can you put
the cap on the pile please you got that
running total in your head oh sorry can
you cover up the pile now
oh sorry
ah now that i made that look like i'd
forgotten to ask you but i needed to do
that
because once i see the top thing what do
i do then
yeah you okay yes you know what the
other one is and add that to 14. yeah or
i just take because 21 would be the the
three sevens i just take that number off
21
and i'm done this is a cheats trick i
engineer some way of glimpsing the top
number and the rest is it's not always
gonna be the same number so it's
repeatable and the rest is just the
sevens like you're working before but i
have to do the the slightly clunky bit i
need to glimpse that top number by hook
or by crook i've got to glimpse it
whether i turn around by accident if i
see the three i do 21 take three and i
get 18.
and if i see the six
what's the stack turtle going to be or
rather when i do the trick with them
so if you see a six on top 15 would be
the answer yeah and we'll check right so
one and two is three
another six makes nine
and a six 15.
it's just the sevens property but again
it's slightly concealed this one needs a
little bit more work to do that oh i've
glimpsed the six but i didn't want to
make it too obvious but like like all
magic tricks there's a mixture of sort
of rational like i've got to engineer
something quite carefully and i've also
got to misdirect i've got to sort of
take the attention away i find it
interesting to look at magic tricks
because i'm a teacher and it's like
literally the opposite of my job
teaching is like explaining clearly so
everything is laid out and magic is
completely mystified so everything is
not laid out what i find interesting is
that they can work together because by
doing a magic trick you provoke
curiosity and intrigue and that can
motivate the sort of the clear laying
out there's a there's a funny paradox in
the world of teaching but anyway that's
a three dice stack dice trick
this was the third in a trilogy of dice
trick videos that we recorded with ben
links to the other two can be found on
the screen or down in the description
the reveal of a magic trick is important
the like the punch line is like how you
cause the wonder so it matters about
getting right now i just i just said the
number which kind of works
but maybe there's more drama if you can
find another way to reveal it so if i
know that i've seen the two then i don't
worry anymore like it's covered and i
sort of like make the most of it being
covered i can't see anything of it but
i'm not even going to tell you the
number i'm just going to say it'd be
strange if i knew what number you were
going to get in advance wouldn't it it
would be strange and almost impossible
for me to just uh pull these things out
i mean that's like interesting wouldn't
it to be to know that there'll be one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 which is
your number
oh incredible amazing
and i don't i don't know if this is a
better reveal or not it certainly feels
normal what i've done is i've put 21
coins in my pocket and the two that are
spotted on top i left in my pocket
really easy to do whatever number i see
there i leave that many in my pocket i
can count through and just throw them on
the table it's kind of like a nonchalant
feeling you can even throw it on the
table and say i bet you the coins is the
same as your total and walk away to the
bar and just wait there until they're
impressed enough to come and buy the
drink
not going to buy many drinks with 21
pence
true we can used to use pounds next time
and unless beer has gone up a lot i
should get something out of it
then of course you've always got to have
uh three dice and 21 coins in your
pocket just in case
is unusual